Now, let's say we have a random sample of ten people who each told us how
many hours they slept the night before and
their temporal memory score on the BBC test. Is
there a relationship between these two variables? Well,
it's very difficult to judge relationships based on
just lists of data. So let's visualize it.
This scatter plot visualizes the data in the table.
Each point represents one row of the table.
Here you can see that the hours slept
was about five and the temporal memory score
looked to be about 55. That must correspond
to this row here, 556. You can see that hours slept is on the X axis and
temporal memory score is on the Y axis. We call the variable on the X axis
the independent variable or the predictor variable. And we call the variable on
the Y axis the dependent variable, or
the outcome. We're trying to predict temporal
memory score, using hours slept. Now that
you've sen this data visualized, what can
we say about the relationship between hours
slept and temporal memory score? This time
this question might be easier to answer.